hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
keep it small aav and lnp
quant and sizing from just micro leaders
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by unchained labs to
learn more visit them at
unchainedlabs.com now we encourage you
to participate today
by submitting any questions you might
have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker
nellis dennis
a product manager at unchained labs
now this you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
thank you for that introduction let's
get right to it with my talk
keep it small av and lnp quant and
sizing from just
mic for leaders
bigger is not always better like in this
case for fido
who had big dreams but is now a bit
stuck here and isn't going to fit
through
the same applies for your gene therapy
vectors lipid nanoparticles need to be
just the right size to deliver
messenger rna effectively while checking
size and watching out for aggregation is
essential for viral vectors like aav
and lentivirus
meet stunner the ultimate gene therapy
tool
stutter is the only system that pulls
together uv-vis concentration
dynamic light scattering and static
light scattering data from just
the same two microliter sample this
means stunner can dig into aavs
lnps and lentivirus samples for all
kinds of info
such as nucleic acid quant sizing and
even
aav titers
stunner combined uv for concentration
and dls for sizing
sls intensity data is also read during a
dls experiment
so low volume high trooper dls to get
the size and pdi data
you need while quantifying dna or rna
concentration
all this is done in a 96 well plate
based format that powers high throughput
analysis
giving you all this data on 96 samples
in one hour
now how does spanner do this simply add
in two microliters into the input well
and it's pulled into the microfluidic
reservoir at this step the sample can
sit for up to two hours before reading
with no evaporation
after the plate is loaded into the
instrument the circuit is read first
when empty
and that will remove any absorbance
contribution from the plastic
and then a pump applies a small vacuum
which moves the sample into the micro
cuvette to be read
because the circuit has fixed path
lengths it can make very precise and
accurate reads
now let's take a look at our
applications first
our completely new rna lnp application
without the need for dilutions reagents
standards or fluorescent dyes
you'll get size polydispersity index
total rna quant and quantification of
turbidity
lnp size is critical to the performance
of a successful drug
throw a stick in the literature and
you'll hit a paper with lmp
size data often showing the link between
size and the effective dose needed
so when you've got lots of buffers
formulations and rna constructs to test
you want to be gathering size data on
everything
stunners dls gives you the high
throughput power to gather the size and
size distribution data
on 96 samples in less than an hour here
we're looking at intensity distribution
data for a whole plate of lnps
with the average diameter noted as the
value below each
distribution you no longer have to be
limited by dls data that has to be
manually gathered for about a dozen
pieces of data in a day
now dls can keep up with lmp samples as
fast as you can make them
on the left you can see an intensity
distribution
the mrna lnp is tested here had an
average hydrodynamic diameter of 79
nanometers plus or minus one percent
which is visualized by the green bar
plot on your right
and it's error bar inside that bar plot
you can see the pdi value as a blue dot
with error bars
showing a pdi of 0.14 plus or minus 0.02
and the dls data is just how you like it
with intensity and mass distribution
hydrodynamic
diameter and pdi values that you've been
using for years
but now you can add the triplet that
lets you get a really great
understanding of the error bars and
distribution you have in your sample
you don't need to stick to an n of 1 for
your gls data
you can run actual triplicate square
duplicates you name it
ok time to switch gears to uvs
any time you try to see through
solutions this cloudy
absorbance measurements done with plain
vanilla instrumentation will have some
issues to overcome
but standard lets you see true to fog
load up an lmp sample into a stunner
sample well and you will quickly see it
being whipped into the serpentine
reservoir
and held there this is shown on the left
to read the plate standard will pump the
sample into the 0.1 and 0.7 millimeter
path length micro cuvettes
for you with this absorbance
measurements when reading
lnps the combinations of stunners two
fixed paddling
micro cuvettes provides precision and
broad dynamic range
since lnps are typically very turbid
cloudy samples
the short path lengths are needed so
that light to pass through
and enable absorbance measurements
here's your quantitative look at all
that turbidity shown by oh comparing the
signal from an empty lnp
so one that is not loaded with a nucleic
acid to a pbs buffer these lmps create a
whole
lot of signal that looks like absorbance
but usually isn't helpful
and just gets in the way
because all that turbidity makes
quantifying the traditional uvs
almost impossible total rna quan by
universe is normally a big challenge
for example if we squint at the full
curve we can see the rna bump at about
260 nanometers
but the difference is pretty small to
analyze this we have to separate out the
signal from the turbidity
from the signal from the lnp absorbance
due to rna and other
lnp components
on the left we have that raw data again
and on the right stunner has used our
unmixed algorithms to isolate the impact
of turbidity and remove it
this is shown by the black line
indicating total signal
and the gray line indicates the
contribution from turbidity
the remainder is in green and blue green
is the isolated signal from rna
and that will be our total rna
concentration and blue is a uvs
absorbent signal from other components
in our sample
uv absorbing lipids excipients and
buffer components
stenner separates the contributions of
those three groups
turbidity rna and other components to
quantify
total rna concentration and less than a
minute per sample from 2 microliters
and without any dice reagents or
complicated workflow
stemmer's rna concentrations agree
closely with the total on
messenger rna concentration determined
by ribogram
on the left is a standard measurement
with n equals seven
and comparing that to total rna
concentration determined with ribogreen
you can see they closely agree the
twofold dilution series of firefly
luciferase
messenger rna lmps showed highly linear
results down to 1.2 micrograms per
milliliter error bars are plus or minus
one standard deviation
and standard gets you everything all at
once not only dls results on 96 samples
of lnps in about an hour
but at the same time you get your rna
concentration
all from that same two microliter sample
we already mentioned turbidity
quantification where turbidity is
normally a massive problem for a lot of
uvs instruments
stunner is able to understand turbidity
and analyze it to tell you a bit more
information what is going on with your
particle
here we are looking at turbidity signal
from a two times dilution series of
empty lnps
you can see that a sample gets diluted
every step
the turbidity also decreases
and it turns out that decrease is very
linear what we are doing here is taking
a sample
of empty or full lmps gray or green
and we measured that particle target
then we've taken that two times the
lotion series and quantified it on
stunner
when stunner quantifies turbidity it is
going to represent that
as absorbance value at 260. if you plot
those values against each other
you see that when you dilute these
samples you get a very linear plot
since turbidity scales with
concentration size and payload
you can build a standard curve with
against particle count
and use standard turbidity
quantification to get a quick result
on your particle count
okay so now let's take a look at our
second application
aav quant when characterizing aav you
have a lot of things going on
it's important to know how much protein
is present how much dna is present
if things are intact if they're the
right size and if there's any
aggregation
it's a truly complex biologic that
demands a lot from characterization
techniques
stunner brings it all together to
deliver answers on capsid tighter empty
full ratio and aggregation
with again only two microliter of sample
in less than a minute
and there's no labels no reagents or any
standards
you just use the sample you've got
so let's focus in on two technologies
dls and uvs
each of them tells a part of the story
dls gets you info on capsid tiger and
aggregation
but can't say anything about what's
happening with dna
on the other hand either this gets you
total amounts of protein dna
and can link those to anti-full ratios
but it doesn't give you info about if
any of this is actually contained in
capsids
so each technique gets you valuable info
but neither tells you everything
so what if you could combine them to get
a whole story
and that is exactly what stunner does
and it's shown step by step here
first the ls identifies the capsids the
aggregates and how
intense the signal is from each of those
populations
in the middle that info then helps you
split up your sls signal from a total
into the amount just attributable to
empty and full capsids combined
and finally uvs brings in that info
about empty full ratio
plus protein and dna totals to provide
the last piece of the puzzle
here's the whole story told in one graph
starting with the left side blue bar
which is a protein in a sample
using this got you the total amount of
protein and here we're expressing it as
how many possible capsids
all that protein could make by adding in
the ls and sls
info stunner splits up that information
into the light blue bar
which is aggregates and extra protein
junk and the dark blue bar
which is the total tide for the aav
capsids
on the right hand side in the green bar
the process follows the same steps for
dna
the total height of the green bar is the
total amount of dna
expressed as the total number of viral
genomes that you can make
light green is extra dna and dark green
is the number of full av
capsids dividing dark green so our full
capsids
by dark blue so our total capsids gets
you to a percent
full number that we also convert into an
empty full ratio for you
now here's that same data showing how
stunner helps you know your aav inside
out
dark green divided by dark blue is
percent full and this is shown here in
yellow
purple is percent empty which is just
remainder
empty full ratio is percent empty
divided by
uh mp4 ratio is percent empty divided
by percent full so here purple divided
by yellow
and if your preferred term is cp per vg
ratio
that will be just the inverse of our
percent full number
to look more into our ability to see
percent full values
we took stocks of empty and full aav9
and mix them at different ratios
for each combination 100 full stock 80
full stock and so on stereo gets a good
read on the data and percent full and
percent empty align well with our
expected values
and this application works for any
stereotype
just tell stannar the basics about what
stereotype you have
and what its dna payload is and stunner
takes care of the rest of the heavy
calculating
now for getting capsule tighter spanner
is way faster and requires less upfront
work than
eliza here with taking full or empty
aav9
and ran a dilution series where we've
compared stunner's total capsid tiger
metric
against the result for capsid elisa the
results have
slopes close to 1 and r squared values
above 0.99
and importantly it would take hours to
get this elisa data
while standard has done it in less than
an hour with no sample prep
assessing aav storage conditions is a
slow process
made even slower when the only
analytical tools you have
are functional essays storage
experiments are made
more complicated because some aav
stereotypes are more prone to
aggregation than others
functional essays might tell you that
you have lost infectious particles
but won't tell you why stunner's dls
shows if a
sample has aggregated so you can tell
when a sample of afv
has gone bad without wasting time on
cell-based assays
standards dls intensity distributions of
aav2
and av9 both stored at 4 degrees for 2
weeks showed aav2 had peaks at much
larger hydrodynamic diameters
than av9 indicating significant
aggregation
the large light blue bar of the aav2
samples
shows the extent of storage induced
aggregation while the dark blue and
green bars
dominating the graph or aav9 show that
most of the sample is intact
full capsids quickly rejecting samples
you
know won't work in a cell-based essay
saves you time and means you can focus
on the samples you know will work
choosing the right buffer and
formulation studies of aav
vectors is absolutely necessary
especially when it comes to ph
if the tools you use to characterize
your aav are too slow or take too much
sample you might miss out on the optimal
buffer
hitting full aav9 to 45 degrees for 25
minutes in a neutral
ph 7 buffer caused some aggregation
but heating it in an acidic ph4 buffer
caused nearly complete aggregation
with its lightning-fast dls reads
stunner makes it easy to evaluate more
buffers and stress conditions than
traditional methods
while also providing you with tighter
results
and if iodicional is part of your
process it is useful to know exactly how
much is in your sample
and to check on the iodicional
concentration after each buffer exchange
standard can help out here as well and
will detect iodine in your sample
as low as 0.0005
by volume
[Music]
so from only two microliters stunner
combines
uvis dls and sls data to tell the whole
story about your aav sample
delivering mountains of data about
sample aggregation av full and empty
capsid tighter
and empty full ratios
now while we have specific applications
for rna lnps and adeno-associated
viruses
sterner will help you with other drug
delivery systems as well
here we can see measurements of a
lentiviral vector at different steps in
the process
the crude sample has some small
impurities and large impurities or
aggregation
choosing ultracentrifugation as next
step shows a nice and monodispersed
lentiviral vector
now when the same crude sample goes
through tangential flow filtration
biofiltration and concentration steps a
lot more impurities and big aggregates
are shown
showing up for this specific sample
standard gives you size and aggregation
so you can check any step of your flow
for buffer impurities and aggregation
to identify the best formulations and
clean up steps
and uv if this can help you as well here
are the absorbance results at 280
are shown in combination with the z
average diameter
standard allows you to find a perfect
concentration without inducing
aggregation and quickly compare between
sample types
processes and batches
we offer iqroq services and standard
software is 21cfr part 11 compliant
with full audit rail and electronic
signature capabilities
to help you achieve full integrity on
your experiments and reports
and stunner has shocking accuracy and
wants to prove it
using the fundamentals tryptophan
standards the accuracy precision and
linearity of the instrument
can be proven at any time at the protein
relevant 280 nanometer wavelength
nod ranged from 20 to 225
be confident about every sample with
data that leaves no room for doubt
and the features don't stop there if you
would like to move stunner downstream we
also have
a performance certification these tests
with certified cuvettes
meet the united states pharmacopoeia and
european pharmacopoeia guidelines
for uvs spectrometers the tests and all
necessary calculations are handled
automatically by the software
in addition to the capabilities we've
discussed so far
stunner also meets the needs of labs
working in larger scales
for these high throughput needs the
plates used for stunner are compatible
with liquid handling
robots the system can be fully
integrated with our api
setup so the robot does all the work for
you from loading the sample to setting
up the experiment to loading the plate
in the system
starting the measurement and finally
exporting the results in your limbs
on top of that you can use play tracking
with barcodes ensuring traceability
so that is how stunner delivers
label-free standard free and hassle-free
gene therapy quant
to the world of rna lnps and viral
vectors
standard helps you characterize your
viral vectors and lipid nanoparticles
so your end product is a perfect fit
now i'll take any question
and thank you so much nellis for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions
as we have time for so let's take a look
we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience
now it's our first question can you
run lnp samples containing
ethanol on this
yeah the short answer there is yes um
we we successfully run lnp samples with
ethanol
concentrations up to 25
the moment you go beyond that
concentration it would be
a test on the sample itself but yes
thank you so much and can this also be
used for gamma
retrovirus we don't have a specific
application for that as with the aavs
but that's
um a bit the same how you would do it
with the
lentiviruses shown which is gamma radio
virus so
you can use standard to quickly get your
dls results and and
get an absorbance measurement and that
way compare different processes or
batches
um on aggregation on size and
if you if you look at your absorbance
you can take conclusions there as well
but we don't have
a specific application for those thank
you so much nellis and
one audience member wants to know do the
virus need
eluded in certain formulation in order
to be read
by the stunner and can the viral
supernatants
which may have other proteins from the
producer cells be read
by the instrument accurately
okay so um to the first part no you
don't need to
um elude it in a special buffer or
anything like that
but for the most accurate results for
the aav
quant was definitely meant for
downstream so most pure samples where no
other proteins would be in your sample
now
if if you would have that problem or
you're a bit more upstream and you still
want to want to check out with stunner
you can of course do do so and check
your different
purification steps to see if that other
protein
goes away the moment you start purifying
and so look at your purification step if
it's really
working as good as you wanted it
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience members for these great
questions
coming in now let's can the analysis
distinguish between ph six seven
and eight so our our system won't
distinguish between any
ph's it's the experiment shown there was
um showing how you can use your
different types of buffer and check for
um differences in aggregation for
example so you will know
what the what your buffer conditions are
and then you'll look at the results and
take your conclusions for there
seeing that page six for example would
have a lot more aggregation than
ph seven that will make you conclude
that ph seven is the better buffer to go
with
wonderful and we have time for several
more questions so keep
sending them in in terms of abundance
now list how do you how do the dls
aggregate peaks translate into actual
aggregate concentrations
so we don't actually give you aggregate
concentrations we give you the
titers of of your perfect capsid
and so we get it tighter from the sls
dls and use this part
and for uvs we get a total amount as
well and so
the aggregates we don't translate into
actual concentration but it's just um
to distinguish the difference between
those
values from those two techniques
thank you so much this next question is
a little bit of a scenario from an
audience member
say i scan multiple aav
serotypes to find the best one for my
insert
can i measure them all on the same plate
yes that's one of the great features
from stunner where you can put
your samples in different sample groups
and so on the same plate you can
have different blanks but also different
server types
there and so it would be no problem to
run them on
on the exact same plate you can still
mark which
samba group is which analyte
and what sample prep do i need to do
that's another great feature of stunner
there's in most cases no sample prep at
all
you just take two microliters you load
it and you run it
and you can walk away while it's doing
the concentration in the ls measurement
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question now is can you
run one sample at a time and if so
how long does that take
uh yes you could so you can um set up
your experiment with as many samples as
you want
we have so the plate can be 1 to 96
samples and you can actually even
specify multiple plates there so yes you
can run
one sample at a time it will take a
couple of seconds for the uv vis
measurement and then your gls
we take a four times five second
acquisition
and as default so that would be under a
minute
per sample thank you it looks like our
audience
members are sending some more questions
in so we have time for a couple more
wonderful i'm working with a custom aav
not a default serotype will that still
work
yes so um in our analyte section you can
we have preset default serotypes or aavs
um but when you're working with a custom
one you can you can make
changes to which viral proteins you used
things like that to change the
refractive index and all those things to
make sure your
ends uh calculations are completely
correct for your or are as good as
possible for your specific sample
and nellis is the stunner compatible
with lims system
yes so um we
in a standalone or in automation you can
get output in multiple formats
csv is the most popular one and that can
go directly in your limb system
so that's no problem at all thank you so
much
and there is a specific software for aav
is there one for lv
so we don't have a specific application
for
uh lentivirus no we have um our general
applications
as was shown in the presentation where
we do um just
sizing and um concentration measurements
and so you there you will still get
aggregation results but there's no
specific translation into titus or
anything like that for
antivirus now nelvis have you compared
your aev genome leaders with
qpcr results
yes we have but i would say first of all
the qpcr will give you
the identity and so it's very space
specific for the dna
you want there and we will give you the
total uh dna concentration so there will
be
in most cases we will be slightly higher
than qpcr
but in general it's a different
technique so um
there will be some it in general
correlates nicely
but there will it won't be exactly the
same
thank you nellis and we have time for
one final question
for aav does viral genome size
affect final leader
yes um the genome size is definitely
important that will have an influence on
the calculations from
the absorbance to your actual uh dna
tighter
and also in the motor weight for the
calculations from sls dls and uv is to
tighter
so it is definitely important um but
our software allows you to enter your
genome size in either if you have one
overall always the same size you can do
it once in your analyte or
you can just with an excel template if
you have 96 different ones for example
you can just import and
the software will do all the rest of the
calculations for you
thank you so much nellis for your
presentation and for your time today
would you like to offer
our audience members any closing remarks
before we go
i would say thank you for everyone that
joined in today and
never hesitate to reach out to us if
you're interested to learn more about
our project
our product and i want to thank you
again ellis for your time and for your
important research
and i'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor unchained
labs for underwriting today's
educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
everyone
bye